[Música]
me gusta la música cristiana
321 ahora
efe
[Risas]
hay música cristiana que es buena y otra
que es mala pero es el mismo tipo de
música con cualquier género tengo que
estar en un determinado ambiente o
estado mental para escucharla estoy un
poco de acuerdo en que algo es bueno y
algo es malo pero como que siento que
entre el 60 y el 70% no es bueno y
emocionante pero tal vez estoy un poco
traumatizado porque solo podía escuchar
música cristiana cuando era un niño y
ahora estoy como
eso podría ser la razón
he dudado de mis creencias
321 ahora
soy gay soy de un pequeño pueblo de
texas y es difícil no cuestionar tu fe
porque te dicen que
los homosexuales no pueden ser
cristianos o que los cristianos solo
pueden seguir ciertas reglas que se
establecen así que para mí cuando empecé
a crecer y a relacionarme con el
cristianismo es cuando mi fe se hizo más
fuerte pero fue sin duda difícil y
todavía estoy pasando por eso hubo cosas
que
sentí que nací sabiendo que dios me
amaba y que dios era bueno y luego
cuando llegué a la iglesia más tarde
había algunas creencias
porque soy gay y la gente era muy esto
es así y no puede ser esto y esto no
ahora rara rara rara pero la razón por
la que estoy en esta línea es porque
nunca sentí eso de dios todavía siento
que él me ama
apoyo a la comunidad lgbt
321 ahora
dice enemigos
cuando mencionamos el apoyo significa
aceptar y yo no acepto los estilos de
vida dentro de la comunidad pero los
quiero quiero lo mejor para ellos por
supuesto que sí creo que debemos ser
malos con ellos en la iglesia creo que
debemos rechazar los de la iglesia no y
lamento que hayan tenido esa experiencia
porque está mal es horrible nadie
debería de ir a una iglesia y sentir que
tiene que huir de ella es interesante
porque lo que más me ha dolido de todo
esto es el idioma con el que hablas que
es más confuso en realidad nadie me
rechazo fue algo más como lo que haces
te quiero pero dios como que te quiere
mandar al infierno tengo amigos
cristianos que son homosexuales o gays y
están luchando se están absteniendo pero
la comunidad dice que no hay nada malo
con este estilo de vida están orgullosos
de ese estatus no tienen remordimientos
ni tratan de alinearse con lo que dice
la biblia literalmente están escogiendo
creer en una parte de la biblia
y desecha todo lo demás hay ciertos
materiales que no debemos usar hay
ciertos alimentos que no debemos comer
pero no discriminamos a las personas que
hacen eso pero si discriminamos a la
gente que ama a alguien diferente si vas
a estar en desacuerdo también tienes que
entender el peso de lo que le estás
pidiendo a una persona gay cuando miras
a alguien y sientes que es atractivo y
tienes que estar en desacuerdo con esa
parte de ti mismo cada segundo del día
tienes que decirte que eso está mal a
cada segundo tú no piensas que no
deberías casarte con la mujer que amas
no digo que deban estar solos digo que
es la base de todo quiero que sean como
dios los creó sé que ustedes creen que
dios los creó para amar de una manera
pero en realidad yo me preguntaría
porque quiero amar a quien quiero amar
porque hay esa atracción solo digo donde
se pone el límite por ejemplo si soy un
hombre adulto y me gustan los niños yo
creo
que no están de acuerdo con eso pero
creo que debe haber líneas porque es
vivir
tú sabes que nuestro que no estás de
acuerdo con eso y yo sé que si es lo
mismo creo que la comunidad lgbt es como
un gran tema dentro de la comunidad
cristiana pero no lo hace peor que por
ejemplo yo bebo y esas cosas y a veces
bebo en exceso lo cual es un pecado pero
eso se normaliza eso no se ataca con
tanta frecuencia como lo harían con la
comunidad lgtb a eso me refiero yo
define el apoyo de forma diferente creo
que se puede apoyar el derecho de
alguien a amar y de sentir amor sin
apoyar la actividad homosexual eso creó
la actividad homosexual es pecaminosa
violar a un niño es pecado podemos
discutir sobre qué está mal o que está
bien o sobre qué ha normalizado a
nuestra sociedad pero al fin y al cabo
todos pecamos todos pecamos de
diferentes formas y ninguno de esos
pecados debe ser celebrado ninguno
debería ser ignorado y todos deberíamos
trabajar no para cambiar lo que somos
sino para ser más como cristo
dios nos ama a todos
321 ahora
jajaja
tienes que dar algunas explicaciones
suena muy bien decir que dios ama a todo
el mundo y si nos ama pero no creo que a
todos por igual el ama a sus propios
hijos más que a los demás en el mundo no
enviaría al infierno a alguien que ama
de verdad él es amor eso es lo que es su
encarnación creo que es imposible que él
no muestre amor hacia sus hijos no creo
que ya diferentes grados creo que todo
está estabilizado todos somos amados por
igual
yo saldría con alguien que no es
cristiano
321 ahora
creo que voy a
[Risas]
estoy casada llevo casi 10 años casada
con un hombre cristiano para mí lo que
siento en la biblia que dios describe
como una familia cristiana son dos
personas marido y mujer que se dedican a
servir al señor juntos y necesitamos a
alguien que nos acompañe y nos ayude a
perseguir nuestro propósito y nuestro
llamado de cristo es totalmente posible
y a menudo sucede que personas de
diferentes religiones o alguien que es
cristiano y que no tiene una religión
son capaces de trabajar juntos y son
capaces de ayudar a la gente a crecer en
su fe estoy de acuerdo en que se podría
aprender de los no cristianos incluso
beneficiarse de las relaciones con
musulmanes budistas u otros no
cristianos pero la biblia es específica
en cuanto a no unirse en matrimonio con
incrédulos ya seas musulmán cristiano o
budista si encuentras a alguien que no
comparte eso cree qué es algo
fundamental para una relación y un
matrimonio pero la cosa es que cuando
des cruzas muchas de las principales
religiones muchos de los principios son
los mismos y como que creemos lo mismo
inherentemente ahí no estoy de acuerdo
creo que somos muy diferentes y en lo
que creemos podemos tener actividades
similares como ir a la iglesia oa la
mezquita pero lo que creo sobre jesús no
lo comparto con otras religiones verdad
además lo comparten
estoy esperando al matrimonio para tener
sexo
[Risas]
321 ahora
me gustaría poder estar allí pero no
puedo por desgracia tomé algunas malas
decisiones cuando era más joven gente
con la que he estado antes siempre hay
una parte de mí con ellos es algo que
nunca se puede recuperar lo que me
molesta mucho porque me gustaría haberme
guardado hasta el matrimonio en todos
los aspectos de las relaciones físicas y
en cuanto al sexo ese barco ya zarpó
pero creo que
como cristiano debería tener citas para
encontrar a alguien con quien estar a
largo plazo o encontrar a alguien con
quien casarse y parte de eso implica
esperar un poco más para tener sexo y
ser de verdad íntimos yo en lo personal
ni siquiera beso hasta que me comprometo
lo cual mucha gente no me cree pero tuve
una relación de dos años y si pasó y fue
muy difícil eres fuerte no me gustaba
pero yo encuentro mucha fortaleza y
cercanía a dios en preservar mi
expresión física de amor por la gente
aunque no es nada nada fácil es algo que
me emociona
poder decirle a esa persona guarde esto
la parte más íntima de mí para ti porque
dios era el único que tenía la llave de
mi corazón antes si muriera ahora iría
al cielo
321 ahora
si no digo que soy una buena persona
pero estoy salvado por la fe en cristo
que perdona el miedo por el pecado sé
dónde puse mi fe y por eso sé a dónde
iré sé que es difícil saber cuáles son
los pecados más graves que impiden a
alguien ir al cielo en especial para mí
no pienso tanto en ello como debería
serlo el cristianismo no consiste en
asegurarse de marcar todas las casillas
para ir al cielo siento que eso nos roba
el cielo que está presente aquí en la
tierra lo único de lo que soy
responsable es de dar lo mejor de mí
cada día y rezo para hacerlo mejor y
creo que eso es cierto para todos todos
somos responsables de dar lo mejor
[Risas]
en mi vida
julie vive intensamente